miren este altavoz si lo enchufamos
suena la forma en que este altavoz crea
sonido es moviendo la parte frontal que
se llama diafragma hacia adelante y
hacia atrás rápidamente los científicos
a menudo usan la palabra oscilación para
referirse al movimiento de un objeto
hacia adelante y hacia atrás este
altavoz oscila demasiado rápido para que
lo vea el ojo humano pero si pongo un
trozo de papel en el altavoz vemos que
debido a que el diafragma oscila choca
con este trozo de papel y hace que baile
la oscilación del diafragma también hará
que el aire frente al diafragma se mueva
hacia adelante y hacia atrás pero aquí
está lo interesante el aire frente al
diafragma en realidad no se aleja del
altavoz las moléculas de aire delante
del altavoz simplemente oscilan de un
lado a otro entonces cómo podemos
escuchar el sonido de un altavoz si el
aire cercano al altavoz no llega al oído
bueno la razón es que el aire oscilante
delante del altavoz hace que el aire que
está frente a él también oscile esto
hace que el aire frente a ese aire
comience a oscilar lo que hace que el
aire frente a él
comience a oscilar hasta que finalmente
el aire que está realmente cerca del
oído y su tímpano comienza a oscilar de
un lado a otro este aire oscilante que
está cerca del oído se mueve entonces
tiene energía cinética por lo tanto
puede transferir energía al tímpano que
puede percibirse como sonido entonces
este altavoz fue capaz de transportar
energía a través del aire sin tener que
transportar el aire este es un hecho lo
suficientemente importante como para que
lo mencionemos nuevamente la energía
está viajando por la habitación aquí
pero el aire en sí no viaja a través de
la habitación solo la perturbación en el
aire viaja a través de la habitación si
el aire se transportará a través de la
habitación se caracterizaría no como
sonido sino como viento entonces es por
eso que llamamos al sonido ondas de
sonido porque comparte la característica
definitoria de las ondas que es poder
transportar energía a través de un medio
sin tener que transportar el medio en sí
medio es una palabra elegante para el
material o sustancia atrás
el cual viaja una onda el aire suele ser
el medio para situaciones que involucran
ondas de sonido pero las ondas de sonido
pueden viajar a través de todo tipo de
materiales diferentes como agua metal o
incluso carne y hueso y el hecho de que
el sonido puede viajar a través de carne
y hueso explica algo que quizás siempre
nos hemos preguntado porque nuestras
voces suenan tan diferente en las
grabaciones de audio y vídeo la razón de
esto es que cuando hablamos con alguien
realmente escuchamos dos contribuciones
de nuestra voz escuchamos la onda de
sonido que sale de nuestra boca a través
del aire y que llega a nuestro oído pero
también escuchamos la vibración de la
onda de sonido que viaja a través de
nuestra carne y huesos a través de
nuestro cráneo y hasta nuestro tímpano
pero en una grabación de audio o vídeo
la única parte que se graba es el sonido
que viaja por el aire por lo que cuando
escuchamos nuestra voz reproducida en
una grabación de audio sólo escuchamos
lo que otras personas escuchan cuando
nos escuchen
entonces la mala noticia es que si lo
que escuchamos en las grabaciones
audio es en realidad cómo sonamos para
otras personas pero la buena noticia es
que la mayoría de nuestros amigos
probablemente no piensan que son amos
raro ya que esa es la única voz que nos
han escuchado usar a menos que nosotros
en realidad tengamos una voz extraña en
cuyo caso me arriesgaré a parecer
pretenciosa al recordar que no debemos
perder mucho tiempo preocupándonos por
lo que las otras personas piensen de
nosotros